هذه التحضيرات التي تجرى الان تحضيرا
لتتويج تشارلز الثالث ملكا لبريطانيا اذا
نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
لعمليات تجهيز او استقدام القوى الامنيه
تحضيرا لبدء مراسم تتويج تشورز الثالث
والتي من المتوقع ان تبدا عند الساعه
التاسعه صباحا بتوقيت لندن
اذا العاصمه البريطانيه تستعد لحفل يعتبر
حفل تاريخي هو الاكبر منذ سبعه عقود
لتتويج تشارلز الثالث في كنيسه وستمنستر
بي لندن
باحتفال ديني ملكي وايضا يتخلله طبعا
اتباع وكل التقاليد التي تعود لحوالي الف
عام بتاريخ العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
بحسب الجدول مشاهدينا من المقرر ان ينطلق
الموكب الملكي لي تشارلز من قصر باكينغهام
الى كاتدرايات
المحاذيه للبرلمان البريطاني حيث ستجرى
مراسم التتويج والصدور طبعا رسم
ولممثلي وزعماء اكثر من 200 دوله حول
العالم اضافه الى نخبه من ممثلي الشعب
البريطاني وطبعا الساسه واللوردات
البريطانيه
التحضيرات الامنيه والتي بدات قبل ايام
يعني تخللها نشر سلطات البريطانيه لالاف
الضباط لتامين مراسم التنصيب في العاصمه
لندن وطبعا خلال هذه المراسم سيعلن زعيماء
استراليا ونيوزيلندا الولاء للملك تشارلز
كما هو معتاد بالحضور الرسميه طبعا سيغيب
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ولكن ستحضر
السيده الاولى التي وصلت الى لندن قبل وهو
يعني
عرف متبع حتى بعمليات التتويج الماضيه لم
يحضر اي رئيس امريكي عمليات التتويج
حتى عند تتويج الملكه اليزابيث والده
تشارلز عام 1953 ارسل حينها الرئيس
الامريكي الى لندن ولم يحضر شخصيا
[موسيقى]
ده المشاهدين نرى الحشود
التي بدات بالوصول منذ ايام يعني حتى
الحشود هي ليست فقط حشود بريطانيه انما
وصلت للدول مختلفه لحضور مراسم
التتويج على طول كيلومتر امام ما يعرف
بمول لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات